what is going on everybody welcome to a
new tutorial series covering how to
build a quadcopter so here's an example
of what we'll be building I'll actually
be building a different one but it will
look very similar to this one just a few
differences so the series is separated
into major parts the first part
intersections really the first section
is about how to actually build the thing
and actually get it to fly with your
typical transmitter and then the second
part is programming with it and using
various sensors and doing you know fun
stuff with Python so most of you guys
are probably familiar with my channel
because you program in Python and with
the channel and I'd like to incorporate
that with the quadcopter but first you
need a quadcopter so the first question
you might ask is you know why would I
build a quadcopter as opposed to just
going to the store and buying one and by
all means if you want to go to the store
and buy one go for it but there are a
few reasons why you wouldn't want to do
that first of all when you're tinkering
with something you're highly likely like
break it fry it and with a quadcopter
crash it so so if you custom build a
quadcopter
replacing parts fixing parts upgrading
parts and all that is just way easier if
you custom build as opposed to just
buying so when you buy a commercial
quadcopter a lot of times they're going
to come with proprietary parts and what
that really means is fancy lingo for we
have a monopoly on these parts so if you
break those parts you have volume like
one person who sells those parts right
so it's monopoly and you pay a lot of
extra money for that so if you custom
build a lot of quad customers the sizes
even the holes that are punched in the
frames and stuff they're all
standardized so you can replace and swap
out parts and upgrade parts and all this
kind of stuff and it's just better also
the quadcopter aside if you custom build
you also get to use your own transmitter
and you can use that transmitter across
you know five six quads and it really
doesn't matter so to me especially if
you think you might be around for a
little bit you might as well custom
build so that said custom building is
really challenging there's a lot of
stuff you've got to learn in a really
short period of time all kinds of stuff
so if you're like me and you're just
entering into the world of quadcopter so
you don't even know that the propellers
been in different directions right I
didn't know that okay
luckily with with the smaller ones a lot
of times things are getting so
standardized now that the threading on
the propellers and the in the shafts and
all that is is reversed so even if
you're totally like new and you didn't
research like I didn't it doesn't matter
you you're still saved but anyway I
didn't know that there were different
propellers even you know it's like
little stuff like that like you just
don't know when you're getting into it
so anyways that's that what we're going
to be doing in the next part of this
video is talking about the supplies that
you need because like right out of the
gate you've got to figure out what
supplies you need but you also need to
make some decisions about what you're
looking for in order to even know what
supplies to get so for example the first
question that you're going to have is
like what size quadcopter should you get
like this is a little 250 is probably
the most popular size at the moment but
even now I mean people are buying like
two tens and stuff like that but
generally this is as small as you get
you might get a 210 that's even smaller
but I'm not really sure out I would
recommend it to 10 but for example this
is a 525 and this was actually the first
quadcopter well the first size squad car
this is my second quadcopter I've got an
identical version of this one it's just
a little too big the propellers are very
big the motors are pretty strong it
causes a lot of damage when it hits
things it's also just more of a
challenge to fly it it's just bigger it
catches wind better better but worse I
suppose I don't know anyway um just a
little too big and now if you're doing
like photography and you want like a
really stable flight you could actually
probably weigh this down a little bit
more and it would be far more stable
than a 250 but that's not really my goal
or my intention so yeah anyway um so now
we're going to do is we're going to
we're going to pop over to this table
over here we're going to talk about all
the supplies that you need so at least
my first plug I'm going to be talking
about size 250 you're not gonna save any
money though building a smaller koala
cuz really the difference between those
is slightly bigger propellers slightly
more powerful motor but you're not going
to pay that much more in a bigger frame
but the frames are the same price so it
really doesn't matter what size you go
for but honestly the 250 is way more fun
so I would recommend it to 50 but do one
so now it's popular in this table talk
about all the supplies that you need
there's a lot of supplies a lot of
information to cover so that's what
we're going to be doing so stay tuned
for that